hello and welcome to city of HS boss
okay to play against my own opening now
I know so we got them the Spanish for
Knights yeah I mean I recently published
this repertoire which includes this line
oh that's not very dangerous okay
eight okay let's actually welcome here
why this just was now I have the idea to
take take on e4 with a fairly
uncomfortable position for white is that
even playable so I take take on e4
[Music]
mmm interesting I can also simply keep
the tension here wonder what what is he
doing next yes that makes a lot of sense
and now I probably have to take now if I
take with the rook continue but both
both captures are quite interesting okay
route Luke takes us the more obvious one
with the tempo and now 95 I think I had
this in my my repertoire recommendation
just with the bishop on G form instead
okay now how is he going to play
probably yeah this is actually nice on
on aged five currently stopping any
route D one I want to play be 65 get
more central control
maybe Queen g7 was an alternative
hmm yeah maybe I mean this it's very
comfortable for black but white is still
a solid of course yeah that's true now
that I miss play dad I really miss my
dad
I was definitely a little bit better and
now this is probably equal and I'm not
happy not happy with my plane maybe
maybe this one with a double a check so
that my pawn structure gets improved a
little bit and then we are playing this
ending we're just very slightly more
comfortable for me he should lose this
obviously but it's not too bad I've got
the somewhat better poor information
okay so look on e4 was probably good
okay I mean if I take it
rook t5 rookie to you will come to the
seventh now I'm probably that it's not
not that helpful
yeah just King f2 I don't think he's got
something something better
yeah and one day if c4 is one of us is
something that white can do I'm just
going to stop that like c4 it takes and
he invades so just be content with with
small things even though Midas
definitely ok him I mean can go rook you
form you know looks kind of okay for him
I mean that I don't mind really
I wants to go see for that submits the
idea but I can take take a for them yeah
that is not helping all that much okay
and then c4 I see yeah that's definitely
possible
bit dissapointing all this after the
opening which was excellent for me and
now it's just absolute nothing Jim
they're quite annoying really yeah
that's very very little that can be done
in this position could offer a draw but
he offers me a draw
Jim
and that is there is a pea after this
terrible opening really terrible is so
strong I'm sorry but I mean this is just
not good for white and I did not really
exploit it to the fullest
so here Bishop f5 is even better with a
clear advantage one night you form
yeah this whole thing is just not good
yeah yeah
why does in terrible shape so that was
already a mistake and he Knight f4 as
possible which gives him a good game
even terrible okay yeah and now I'm
better again and I'm not exploiting it
which is bad really b6 is just too lame
Queenie 7 Queen g5 it's all better for
me yeah and this is just he's ok again
really I mean I have a very slight
advantage but and this is just it's just
too soft he's able to get rid of his
pawns and then it's a draw now that's
bad this is this is Bishop c5 one of the
reasons why this is a good line it said
this is really bad
I mean bad in context of taking only 5 I
mean you can do this sorry we can do
this which is very unambitious but
playable of course but this is just
pretty and pretty terrible idea because
this is just very good from like the
best is this one and then we get it
slightly in comparison for him slightly
better version of the this whole thing
which is also of course an advantage for
black but it's a little bit better than
the game because he had this additional
option or 94 which would have killed him
probably okay yeah what can you do
thanks for watching